what's with the jeans welcome to your
mom's house yeah it's your main mommy
Tommy I made it back and Redman welcome
again listeners to your mommy's house
that was a very aggressive open so it
was obviously it was military and
involved
yeah inspired yes because we're here to
celebrate not just another episode but
the fact that you're back here in one
piece overseas you're back from from the
Malloy from the devil it's the most
wonderful place on earth FK the devil's
asshole it's so beautiful there Sun and
sand and rocks it's good to see you babe
thank you I'm glad to be back it was a
very traumatic - I went went with Sarah
Tiana and Jody Miller and Tom - yeah we
we went to Afghanistan we entertain our
troops and I let me describe Afghanistan
to you guys if you've never been there
have you been there Tom I have not been
to Afghanistan
the way I like to describe it is if
you've ever seen Africa I've been to
Somalia and Somalia is nothing but sand
and garbage piles so imagine if Somalia
took a dump like a diarrhea dump and
then instead of using toilet paper
it used errant feces to wipe its own ass
and that's Afghanistan somebody took a
shit and then wipe their ass with the
own with the shit itself and that's did
you guys how would you wipe your shit
with how would you wipe your ass with
shit because there's no you they do what
they do with their left hand that's why
you never shake so you're saying that
Afghanistan is fucking awesome terrible
did you stay at sandals did you see
sandals
I stayed on bases we stayed in Kandahar
which is a NATO base with 40,000 people
and in Kandahar they had a poo pile it
was a poo river yes and it churns the
poo from the entire base so you shit and
burn shit
and then I'm oh and then I at this camp
I think it was called Delhi I shit into
a plastic bag
they're called wag bags that's also a
new plastic bag and I threw that plastic
bag into a fire pit you know what
watched it burn I've never done that
never lived until you've done that I
shouldn't know a plastic bag and put it
in a friend's pillowcase no fire but I
shit into a plastic bag in college I did
I put it in a friend's pillowcase we
knew he was gonna be home for another
day so then we're like well it's gonna
fuck up that room so I took it threw it
outside it kind of cooked in the Sun for
a day and then I went and got it and put
it back in his pillowcase and then we
played cards and we we we watched him
find it and now it's my friend red red I
love you how did you get who got rid of
it who got rid of it
he he went he laid down he was like
we're playing cards and he goes my
fucking shoots focus and we just act
like nothing's going on and then he he
took the pillowcase and he was like what
and he saw it fall out and he he threw
it across the room he was very very well
I can tell you something your shits
don't smell very good
what the fuck did we eat can we talk
about the smell we weren't we both have
had really powerful shits today what did
we eat that created that kind of shit I
think it's a toss-up between scallops we
made scallops last night yeah Indian
food
I don't think that's a cos you shit like
that you didn't have any Indian shit I
bought it this morning and it smelled
like first you sewage did it's not like
like old produce cuz I hate that that
that's you know I think that has to be
some because sometimes I'm like wow that
doesn't smell like shit that smells like
a sewer system that's like it smells
like frogs are living in my butthole do
you think is it like an outdoorsy
garbage yeah kind of like a dumpster or
a rotting produce yeah there's a guy in
our neighborhood
that looks like Kyle Kinane of Kyra Kyle
Kinane were homeless and he smells I
think you gotta take it further than
that
Kyle Kinane does look homeless I think
it would be like if Kyle Kinane were
like a prostitute
Oh fucking guys in a dumpster then this
guy would be him yeah this yeah
sometimes your shit does smell like our
Lakes like streets like a street fair
hot yeah
it's that kind of I think it's garlic to
garlic can make your boom-boom smell
real man well then you remember I should
I don't know if you remember this i shit
yeah and then you went in there you were
very upset at the smell yeah
do you guys have one bathroom yeah yes
well I'd only sucks because I have to
shower in his Pook loud window he lets
it percolate it's it's fucking June at
Silver Lake we're gonna you know a/c in
there and it's cooking he's proud of we
have AC we some have AC in the bathroom
and not in the bathroom yes he's
festering cooking well do you guys have
a fan let's let's uh no before I would
not no no it's really old what let's
introduce our special month my favorite
things one of our favorite people in the
world very a really unique mommy he's
half Italian half Armenian yep if you
love me as a comic you can thank him if
you hate me more which is what probably
most people do you can't blame him yeah
because he definitely was a catalyst for
me getting involved in stand-up he's the
one the only
lovely the kind a huge hearted great
hairdo big bow nerd huge cock loving me
the hog is going bad today the one and
only Sam triply yeah thank you it's good
to be in the in the seat man we gotta
get a sponsor for the seat no I'm saying
like
Goodyear tires yeah of course this is
also seat we neglected to say you are
obviously a death squad regular and
you're the host the creator of the Noddy
show in the naughty podcast yes I'm very
honored to be going the war with you
guys buddy no naughty show you have this
Saturday right well I have a one
Thursday night and then well actually
Thursday through Friday through Sunday
we have shells we have one in Hollywood
and then we're going to Vegas
a place called treasures it's a
gentlemen's club real in steak house
they're really going for it bro
sometimes does those places have
actually excellent steaks no this
they're known for their stay yeah as
much as their dancers they're known for
its like sets for you awesome stuff
there's the one in Florida the the
woman's nature Rachel it's the best
fucking depressed ever it's like the
size of an arm as a shrimp is not no
joke if you're like I want a fucking
steak that's gonna just not hold my ass
but the thing is job you don't want stop
shop you don't have to want the pussy
you can just be like I want the steak
yes they do I swear do you know no it's
totally dying we're going to rake up get
us naked treasures come hang out it's
like treasures is like if Michael Bay
made a strip club that's what it would
be like that's this but you walk in
you're like wow and they're they're huge
they're like mansions out there like
Saddam Hussein mansions
they're like gaudy and the inside but
they're humongous three floors so I mean
they're doing so well that they're all
putting on an addition yeah and it's
gonna be a three-floor theater that they
want yeah that they want to do - Nadia
Jones this is a big show for you right
yeah this weekend's pretty big man we
got Jenna Hayes coming up oh that's a
big don't know don't don't question I
just go with it man I just I vibe with
these girls like things through you know
the series of like two or three years
I've done it like little things have
happened I'm like oh the big thing that
you that you do I think to have these
girls want to do a work with you is you
don't pull your dick out right never
right
I've never fucked any of the girls in
the show I've never hooked up with them
never done anything with this - you're
the damaged girl whisperer I really have
it I really do you think it is about you
that they trust and respond to so well
you know I just I have a way of dealing
with them because III you know Believe
It or Not comedians and porn stars and
strippers are very much alike sure and
once you realize that you can't you
shouldn't really be judging and plus I'm
a freak so I'm like I'm cooled at all
you know I'm saying I don't judge man
when I when I went to college and I
graduated I was doing stand-up in Vegas
so I decided to give myself a little
graduation present
so it went worked at deja vu' showgirls
broke but the nicest people I've ever
worked with
there's no like corporate stabbing to
get to the top because they're all just
there to make a dollar yeah and they're
all working together so it's like nice
people it's a straightforward industry -
100 % mean you know what you're getting
and everyone knows what's up tonight a
great weird damage is shit we're all
crazy like you two are so like normal
you know I just came from my therapist
believe me yeah my theory about
therapist is like they're just
deprogramming
like that's what we're dealing with
right now I think she's trying to
normalize me and I'm like you don't do
that because that's the that's the magic
right that allows me to be right I'm
with you like someone me get on some
hyperactive pills and I'm like and then
I felt like I was my brain was wrapped
and that's not my standup because my
stamp is in the moment of like going I
see something I just run with it and try
to do like five minutes on it sure but
when I had that I was like sticking to
the script and it can't be your fucked
up enjoy it that's right when we did we
went to San Francisco oh yeah outbreak
monkey over here I've never seen a
sickness spread like that house it was
houses you were sick he's still super
crushed but I was fucked up no you were
you were you were and but I'd never seen
you like literally touch somebody and
they're like you're sick
dude I fucking had that's the worst I've
ever felt that was the that's the worst
infection I feel like I've ever had
that's not you're in the hospital yeah I
uh as soon as we got home boom I had it
Joe Hamrick Joe was like you he was so
yeah and then I would I would confide in
Sam I'd be like I think he's mad at me
no he's alright I was like nah he's not
a fucked everyone but Sam like he was so
fun
he would open the shows because he's so
much better at like dealing with people
and having like great energy and you
would just pick people apart yeah and
the fuck that's my thing
yeah to show boom-boom he would he would
lay into like this like six guys in the
front row and the show would it would
become like a party by the time by the
time Stan was Sam was done with only a
set it was a fucking party can I just
ask you something so I was with Sarah
Tiana for two weeks in Afghanistan yeah
and she told me about the funniest
goddamn thing I've ever heard apparently
maybe you can elaborate on this that you
have a second act that you're doing now
I think improv oh yeah it's called
alternative Sam I've seen that yet would
I heard about it this is brilliant
police I basically come on skinny jeans
that's my mom's sweater some glasses and
I just really give my hair so I look
like Yusuf yeah I get I look very
lesbian yeah yeah I go up on stage and I
just do all my jokes but completely like
alternative comedian where it's like
like a throw away yeah just there and
then like there's the punch lines either
rape or AIDS like somehow work that in
yeah and it killed it was really funny
and really did this yeah oh it's the
complete same jokes too there's a work
different does the audience react
different you see it in the comics on
the left in the back laughing and the
crowds enjoying it because they know
what I'm doing right so I mean it's not
like when I normally do my set I'm like
you know I'm focus and it's boom boom
boom boom
but there is something weird about like
I've done a good number of alternative
shows and like sometimes I'll do clubs
for so long without doing one they'll
get anxiety about playing like this alt
show yeah and and basically what I find
is that like it you you will kill you'll
do great if you have your jokes but you
like it's almost like it works better if
you act like like this isn't my opinion
or strut it's like a you you you're just
like lost in the moment and you're kind
of thinking of playing in you stammer
more and you go like you know what's
great these people you see that I don't
do that at the beginning of it and then
they're on board but if you go like
Brady fucking crazy then they're like is
this a joke well ya asshole this is a
fucking stand-up comedy show yeah yeah
that's what we do we do jokes you have
to be self-deprecating you can't just
have an opinion it has to be like I hate
myself everybody yeah and then it's just
weird man it's weird it's like the same
thing with like alternative music and
like kind of like I don't know with the
guys like Death Cab for Cutie it's like
so anti rock yeah and it's so anti
comedy like like some like um Zach
Galifianakis like some people consider
them alternative I think he's just a
funny motherfucker yeah he has some
jokes I'm just like that's the funny
shit I've ever heard yeah so I don't
know how that's alternative yes it's a
setup and a punch it's same thing with a
Patton Oswalt or you know or even David
Cross where people are like those are
the the champions yeah all world but
they're brilliant comics that can play
any room yeah and those are all great
stories or jokes or setups you know Ross
is just as dirty as we are yeah yeah I
mean I watched as long as old special I
mean just retarded kids fucking stuff
it's just like which i think is classic
rock it's not funny and then one other
one before was shut up you fucking baby
yeah he's great I love them all it's
like funny people I don't have like a
certain test he has the one about the
he's like but the one thing we need to
thank George Bush for
is that he still has found it in himself
in his heart to execute retarded people
and he does the thing about how a
retarded person doesn't know he's going
to be executed he thinks he's going for
a ride so you put him in the seat when
he goes seatbelts for my arms it's
brilliant it's fucking brilliant men
circus PJ mispronounces spaghetti
speaking of the Sunday comics have you
ever seen that that there's that one
comic that's kind of a soap opera like
like who's a few of them like who reads
that to keep it like oh my god what's
gonna happen next like oh oh yeah it's
probably the same people that are out
picketing Disney right now I don't know
if you saw this or not there was like
six people holding up this sign that
says you know save our soaps and they're
all over the 400 pounds they're all
women wearing like you ever see the
episode of The Simpsons where where
homers wearing the gown or the 90 the
muumuu right they're all wearing muumuus
and then there was one guy with all
these fat girls and I'm thinking who is
this guy that that's actually out here
picketing Seattle's so weird what we
just likes fat chicks yeah party by the
way there is a study I listened on
savage love podcast there was a study
done on human sexuality
turns out guys are googling and
searching for big women that's one of
the big I love big chicks yeah I'm
totally in the Amazon girls like fad or
Amazon you mean tall no I like tall and
thick yeah like who like give me like
who's like like Winslet no no no no I'm
talking like Brooke Hogan like I'm not
even like her not her face but that kind
of build yeah just big thick Amazon I
like that shit too I like it yeah yeah
like a 6-footer like six-one see women
think guys like like dicks not what
we're into man
like meat on the bone you got to look
into this study actually because you
realize that the last time basically
these this doctor said that the last
time this type of study was done was
when Kinsey when kins what just happened
these two Asian women can't just came to
my door and they're holding things I'm
like hey look I'm really busy I'm not
interested in women we're not selling
anything and I'm like all right what do
you need she goes have you ever heard of
God your mother I'm like is this a
religious thing and they're like why I'm
in here dude and I'm like look I'm
filming a porn in the other room they
just go god bless and walked over here
alright back to this though
the last time that they did it like a
really massive study was when Kinsey did
it in like 1950 something so this guy
was part of a group that studied like
billions of searches oh yeah and it was
in they were able to break that was the
first time that they would they use this
much comprehensive information to find
out what people are actually into yeah I
mean like yeah it's weird and the big
girls was a huge part of it yeah
tremendous and also melts older women
older women yeah I mean and even
grannies know grannies are popular now
it's like weird what what is that though
I don't know my taboo of like yes a
woman who gave you butterscotch candy
you sat on her lap and now you're gonna
stick now you're gonna rocker yeah it's
just weird is that yeah I think that is
it's just like I mean everybody's in the
weird shit man yeah yeah that's one the
naughty show really is about and that's
what I want my podcast again to where I
started bringing in like people or in
really like weird fetishes and I just
want to explore like how do you get to
that well I just bringing back to Dan
Savage his podcast he talks about all
these different things and how they
evolved from childhood if you liked your
your raincoat when you were a little kid
you liked the feeling of your raincoat
well guess what you're gonna develop a
raincoat fetish well I had a UH for when
I went to college in UNLV one of my
professors was like the number-one sex
therapist in the country and he told the
class I don't know how this came up but
he's like I could get anybody to be
attracted to
anything it's really easy all I have to
do is have them look at it when they
orgasm and you do that enough times now
you you start it's like Pavlov's dog you
start being conditioned that that is
sexy so whatever it is you're having
orgasms and weird shit whatever you see
there he's gonna start being like a
turn-on for ya like the guy that came on
his car people objectify like not living
things yeah and this guy was like a
fuckin I have sexual relationships like
how many of those people are on math
it's gotta be a math well a woman had it
with with a wall the Berlin Berlin wall
she just humped the Berlin wall fuckin
loves it
she has replicas of it at her house to
sleep with does she strap on like that
that suction dildo on there and just
Rock her jaw up her ass crazy she
wouldn't but she wouldn't go into detail
she was ashamed of it
my girlfriend's actually getting spanked
right now and the whole fetish of being
spanked I don't get because she comes
home she's gonna come home tonight with
a black ass spanked well they sure hard
they spank her so hard that she
seriously her her skin breaks out and
gets bloody and someone's and she's like
as you like it she's like I don't it
doesn't bother me but I guess you know
spankers pale pretty decent compared ya
you know where the fetish the more
they're willing to pay for yeah and so
like right now she's just kidding but I
don't get that at all cuz I can you
imagine watching watching something and
just be like oh yes Bank are harder but
that's the thing that's the thing about
the fetishes is that like well somebody
else goes I don't get it somebody else
is fuckin losing them 100% into it yeah
hundred-percent into it and the internet
now let you know you're not alone
that's the thing when you see the number
of pages devoted to whatever it be
spanking or raincoats then you go oh
there's this isn't just for for me there
dude there is a thousand videos on
YouTube of dogs dry humping people they
all have at least 5 million views really
yes dog humping there's tons of them
just people getting dog humped look at
that man and it's hilarious yeah because
people just unknown helps to people
the one I don't get and I saw humping I
can even wrap my brain around yeah
they've got like five million views oh
but is he doesn't actually know it's
just it's it's just trying trying on
thing well I knew a guy in the valley
that used to jerk off his dog like we
would go to his house this is woody
charge admission Troy hey this is Don
Barris getting home to uh
really Donna's dombarris is a huge leave
uses a half this one only has 1 million
one hundred thousand there's somebody
who's really enjoyed this one has 22
million let's see a million yeah 22
million dog hunting it's like nice
little that looks like the woman that
just came to my door
god is beautiful or something like that
now I see why it's like five different
fetishes a camera dog camera dork chicks
you got that dirty feet dog humping six
million I'm out here writing fucking
scripts they have storylines character
development
lighting why am i doing it oh this one
I've seen as soon as you there's a
there's a you've seen this yeah there's
a bug inner ear that's the whole thing
can I tell you I get all this I can wrap
my brain around it you know I don't feel
it but I get it you're gonna make money
are women into fetishes absolutely
absolutely
I'm a dance average so am i personally I
don't think so I have I have obscure
fantasies but here's the one I don't get
is scat no I don't get that either
that's exactly right
house ever become popular I do not want
to punch somebody in the face when they
did that it's like early beatboxing
did you guys remember when I don't even
know if it's called scat that whoa
what's that music that was whatever I
would have been a pretty popular that
was kind of like that for it was like
line dancing in bars though there was a
point where they're like that music was
so big at a certain point that people in
at least Columbus Ohio were starting to
dance like that
it's so you're talking about yes it was
begging like no it was starting to get
big in like the 98 late 90s like the
Brian whatever Orchestra yeah oh you
mean big-band swing dance was annoying
there was due to riot Zoot Suit riot and
then there was what's the other kind
called not just not just swing dancing
but a big band
right yeah it was called something else
oh yeah with like a lot of like there
was horns and then it was like Maggie
Mighty Bosstones kind Oh God yeah it's
not the same but it's special cause like
what it's like like reggae with with
Punk so it's like the specials and no
dough
all right Sam you don't know about this
but we have dental updates and we were
wondering if you had any dentist updates
lately how are you my teeth are very
good here's a fine story about my teeth
growing up my teeth got drilled
constantly this fucking doctor it all
you got like three cavities then I go I
grow I graduate and go to college go to
dentists all-time never had another
cavity ever well they're all filled
though this motherfucker
this motherfucker paid his mortgage off
my there okay there okay now also they
could be better we were talking about
just you know young Sam in Vegas doing
his thing yeah you need this champ yeah
bang it Jim and I started to laugh so
hard I was like what cuz you were like
you know you you you definitely played
the game back then you had a lot of
chicks yeah I was uh I was like what
were you like he was like I was like the
lead singer of Soundgarden go with a big
Armenian nose but the long curly hair
and what is your game like what was your
game picking up chicks I was like the
the alpha male of the comedy so you were
yeah yeah yeah I'm right out the gate I
was you know jo koy we don't get along
we've never gone long he's uh not he's
an interesting human being as tripley
1992 yeah wait he started there too
yeah yeah when we started it was like it
was like you were either in one camp or
the other camp no shit no shit I didn't
I wasn't aware that it was always clear
I'm a lover do you know maybe I'm too
idealistic sometimes but you know it's
like I like to fucking take care of the
good people and fucker help people out
you know and that guy at that time was
totally different than that was like it
was just always a win and he had to be
he had the win and he had the you know
all the time and I was just always
community I always think groups rise
that's why
always think that's why I like I loved s
quad and that's why I think it's doing
really well because groups rise man
everybody works with each other sure
puts each other in projects that's how
that whole UCB or the alternative scene
that was what happened yeah you know
even the you know back in the 90s with
the fuck in a Def Jam all those comics
working together putting each other you
know that's how and that's why I tried
to do and then in Vegas and he wasn't
really into that and we just kind of had
bad blood since then I got you but back
in the day Triple E had long hair
crushing it see I didn't really get laid
in high school really yeah because in
high school
funny isn't sexy yet right that's
totally I had a good friend tell me that
you know hey if I didn't know you I'd
literally think you were retarded that's
what I got told
so but the minute I went to college shit
change it's like fast too and it was
like it was did you go to high school in
Vegas - no I grew up in upstate New York
and then you went to UNLV yes now my dad
is hilarious convinces me to go to Vegas
and I'm like Mommie of Vegas and it
turns out he wanted me to buy a house so
he could fly to Vegas as a tax write-off
once a fucking every six months so I
could gamble seriously oh my dad he's a
professional gambler he is oh yeah my
dad bangs black chicks professional
gambler my dad is cooler than I am yeah
my dad's a pretty badass too that's Sam
Triple E senior well he's yeah he's a
senior yeah that's him
is that really him yeah that was a great
timing I guess this might be him yeah so
uh it was great dad like oh yeah but he
likes fart jokes I remember when I first
started like talked up a fart jokes to
laugh at that but does he get what you
do like you know I mean like somehow
he's are like like yeah like they don't
fucking get it you know no not first
yeah well was your parents first advice
like you know when you first start doing
stand-up your folks really like my mom
was like you know what you should do
you should wear a tool belt yes your mom
Jamie Masada yes pretty much
and she's like you should talk about all
the tools on your tool belt yeah this is
she's stealing Tim Allen's acting giving
it to ya my mom wrote this what do you
mean I stole it from you my mom wrote
this entire Act be fuckin crazy
yeah that was re just fuckin baby up
that was my most beautiful moments all
right my mom told me when she asked me
she were talking on the phone about like
how bad the economy was taking a dive
yeah and this was like late Oh eight
early oh nine and I gave her like an
explanation of like a pretty simple
explanation of like well what what's
going on yeah she was like that was such
a good explanation you should do go into
finance oh yeah and you can do your
shows at night where you tell me to like
get a new career right yeah and she was
like well I mean you know it's more
security and I was like cool Thanks
never you're doing it that's the
funniest thing yeah I know like where
you're at it's like a lot of people
don't get to all the time she first can
i I have to tell I know I've been told
everybody that's price to tell everybody
that like you are a huge reason why like
why I did stand-up like we we met when I
was 23
yeah I just Groundlings in the growlings
and you were fast dude I'm like this
kids fast he's so cute oh yeah he was
really fast I was like damn dude I got
up my game I don't know if I ever caught
up with you I was a little older than
everybody else but you were like you
were one of the best in the class well
Sam goes uh
he goes I I kind of secretly had a boner
for stand-up but like that's why I saw I
go God that guy's got a hard-on he's
holy erect laughs he goes you should do
we had uh that one chick that was
banging in there there was cat person
no that was banging the one of the guys
in Lincoln Park yeah it was a bj and the
bear hit the guy who drove the truck
yeah his his daughter and she was all
Kings also yeah that was no that's a
girl that was dating the Lincoln Park
guy okay okay yeah and then there was a
cat
who
what does she what's her last name
Reitman reitman yeah cat reitman she's
really talented funny yeah and I knew
she was gonna be her her thing is that
her voice is so much older than she has
this like very worldly voice yeah she
has to catch up to but she'll be working
a lot too and she's doing great she
books badass but then I he goes you
should try stand-up and I go I don't
know what to do instead of like going
somewhere and he took me around and back
then I don't know if you remember you
took me to you did a spot at the sushi
place on Sunset remember these tough
shows yeah was it called it was a cross
street from Dublin yet it was the DVD
ran a show there and Sam did that and
then he goes to the store and then
somewhere else yeah you want to tripoli
run yeah he was like and then he was
just like that's how you do it bro just
crush it out you would have gone into it
eventually but you know you got to take
him with the great one to see it no see
when I moved to LA I would always hear
about how like New York City comics get
up like 90 times a night and they
totally do and they're great comics so
I'm like you know I gotta get up a lot
out here so I just started running and I
would do like five sets a night yeah all
over the place and this is before a
bunch of the comedy clubs open up I'd be
like to the store then I go all the way
out to Inglewood do like mix nuts in the
club that black comics wouldn't even
play yeah like fuck no I ain't going
there I go out there gig there get
enough gas money go next place and just
run run run run and then I want to start
doing the road and I and I like chaos
yeah
that's why I don't like doing comedy
club you bring chaos I love it I love it
so much yesterday's podcast was can we
get into this
because I work we've been dying to find
out we didn't I asked you and then I was
like you know what let's save it for
this one people are acting like the
world came to an end yeah
no it didn't it was one weird show what
happened it was going good to a certain
point and then she kind of shut down
we'll give us from the start what red
band apology because it's not your fault
man I didn't know that I forgot that she
was underage I thought she was 21 and
she's drinking a beer and I really
regret that is this a girl in the
business yeah well she'd stopped for a
while but she's getting back into it and
I just like her like weird kind of
energy and she was supposed to come with
her friend and she just came by her cell
we know her name her name her her name
is uh uh Mia Miley amia Miley okay and
she's she's a good person she just like
you know here's the thing like you know
it's like I'm blessed I'm doing your
show and we can converse and I can carry
it you can carry it you know everyone
could be quiet sometimes these girls who
come on they don't have that and you
know and some of them are really funny
and it's almost like they're a unicorn
at that point because they're like
really hot they're super filthy and
they're very entertaining yeah
which you don't see all the tonight you
don't know you don't and this happen to
be a girl that kind of got a little
stage fright and she didn't know what to
do and I was trying to pull out of her
and then the big the biggest problem I
had was because I actually I mean the
video to me is great because you know
you have a hot chick and stuff like that
but for the most part you have to
remember that people are listening to
this and so we kept on telling her you
know people come in here once in a while
you'll have where they don't get the
podcast they don't understand the idea
of having to talk into a microphone and
stuff like that sold a lot I mean
throughout the podcast she was standing
up she was walking around she was not
talking in her mic and then she had her
driver boyfriend whatever guy that was
next to us that was adding things to the
whole entire conversation the whole time
off microphone so it became a point
where I'm sitting her going like half
this podcast you can't even hear and
then there was a point where she started
like doing this the whole time where
she's clicking the can and then it was
just like she was she did it the
no answer at some point she would start
just getting quiet and it just went
weird but I don't mind that I mean like
I was like it was like Late Show Friday
yeah like there was some fucking weird
shit going on yeah you know some people
are being entertained some people aren't
I just I love the chaos and the biggest
thing it's like you know and here's what
I would always want is like just text me
next time be like dude this shit this is
shitting the bed let's get out so I can
end it like okay man it's cool because I
don't want her leave and going oh I did
awful that's not really my style and I
think I think I don't think well I think
a normal person leaving that would say
okay I understand why they're ending it
early I I said I don't want to talk to
you know she did I don't want to talk to
you right now I'm like okay which I just
I just know where she's like kind of
like a butterfly she flutters around she
says stupid crazy stuff and she left and
then yeah when she said that I was like
okay this she doesn't want to talk she
doesn't even want to be here doesn't
want to talk so I was like alright we
gotta end this
you know I so I just tried to end it
fast and now because I honestly thought
we're not going to be able to put this
on iTunes I know we're not gonna no
one's gonna listen it's not your fault
it's my fucking fault
I mean I don't I'm not apologizing for
her apologizing that I didn't handle it
better you know I don't think it was as
bad as Twitter's making it out to be and
I just thought it like it was going good
when she smells that and it's we're
having fun and then something just
changes and it goes bad yeah and you
know I would have liked to been able to
maybe explore like what Chris snaps
going into and stuff like that where
maybe we could shifted from I tried to
with the electronic cigarette but yeah
it's so obvious like okay and like
everyone room go hi okay red bands not
enjoying this moment I was it got to the
point where the podcast to me was just
unlistenable and like even to myself
you I tried to save it a few times and
then it just got worse and worse and
worse and they went it like it sounds
like though that this was just like you
know she got freaked out but yeah really
well and then it just went weird and she
really
a nice person yeah super nice girl and
she's you know she's not the smartest
person in the world and that doesn't
make her a bad person no you know I mean
I've done thirty-one shows hey you know
personally I don't like maybe three of
them most people probably would say two
of them weren't the greatest but you
know that's not a bad batting average
I watched Bill Maher on there's like
he'll go like two weeks in row were like
the guests just suck and I'm like well
he's just pulling you know so it was
just weird but it is hard when you get a
dud and you think she's gonna be great
and then people just clam up so I guess
I mean what do you do I guess you just
you just end the show early yeah which
is what we did but I would like to have
ended it a little differently that's all
I'm asking and you know what I'm very
appreciative being on the channel that's
all it is cuz you know I don't want
anybody going going you know I fucking
shit the bed and that's not what happens
yeah I tell you what you know I was
thinking that if you are subscriber on
iTunes I might be throwing this up as a
bonus content to reward the iTunes
people because honestly with all our
podcasts that's the only thing really
that we need is iTunes subscribers
because believe it or not it doesn't
matter how good of a show we do if if
we're if we're not I like high up on the
iTunes ranks it then it's harder for us
to get guests it's harder for us to be
like hey come on to our show you know
it's hard for us to if we ever want to
get a sponsor so do you think we show I
think when situations like this happen
and there's been a couple other things
where I haven't put on you know I've
taken down for whatever reason stuff I
think we're what we're gonna do is we're
gonna start adding little bonus content
from for the iTunes subscribers so it
this is probably not gonna be mi a
forever I'm not sure if we're gonna
release the video or not cuz like you
said we didn't know this girl was under
21 and she brought beer and so we're
like why are you just girl we can't
really advertise that so well you just
did yeah what you did - yeah I wasn't
going to bring that up but yeah how do
we get the subscribers up I mean like I
thought we were doing pretty good now
well tape it off well the thing is
people want are watching you stream
instead people are listening to it on
stitcher radio which is fine you know we
love stitcher and Ustream and all that
stuff but it's it's taken away from the
big thing
that we really need which is the iTunes
listeners so even if you don't even use
iTunes just subscribe to us you know I
fucking download and delete it you know
they can give a shit this is actually
really fascinating to me is like you you
know
everybody in this business like in
entertainment always waits for something
that you hear comments all the time like
what isn't happen for me ya know but you
like how did you come about with the
naughty show concept you you created
this yeah and that's taking off like
it's really growing it's I'm very
blessed it's doing well I'm doing it all
on my own so it's taking longer than I
was hoping but it is it's got good
traction I mean obviously it's comedy
you're a comic your comic you're a lot
of fun to watch perform you like tits
and you like chaos it's kind of a
combination everything you know it's
like uh I grew up on like Kennison and
dice and Richard Pryor and Eddie Murphy
it was like raw shit that was really
funny where you're like okay I'm leaving
my office where I can't say anything
because I don't want to offend anybody
and I'm gonna go watch some guys say
some fucked up shit yeah and I'm like
that's what I like and I don't see it
anymore right I see so much of like you
know like I'm not lying to you I told
you this before you're half an hour is
literally the only half an hour I heard
anything about because just this comedy
is going on now is just like it's such
minimalist my presenter yeah you're
literally the only one no I saw this
when you weren't here it's like I you're
the only one I've heard anything about
because it's just so not about being
funny anymore you know what I'm saying
and I miss that and that's what I want
from the naughty show this kind of come
up in like punch you in the face fucking
have fun go and whoa that's real shit
right there for those people who haven't
been that's what the live show is like I
mean the the live the naughty show you
go to the nightly show and you're like
what the fuck like it's it's a mixture
of it does feel like it's an experience
right because the show starts off I
think the one that I went to there was a
pole dancer yeah we start off with pole
dancing right so you see a stripper
but Nike doesn't strip but they they I
mean this sounds like some bullshit like
someone's saying like I get played away
for the articles but there's such
amazing performers that like they should
be Olympic they should be Olympic they
are not lying to they're amazing so you
see that and you're in a comedy club and
you're like holy shit and then Sam comes
up he's fucking looking sharp he's in a
suit I do a suit man fucking what 42
regular
no I don't even know what's up there he
looks sharp you open the show up it's
like it's just like you know Letterman
or somebody coming out you do jokes you
get Pete you're the fucking you're the
ringmaster right and then you uh you
know then you bring up like a comic you
have so it's almost like a comic guest
yeah
comes up you do time we've both done it
you do at times you both rush I didn't
even know you that well back then you'd
been recommended because I always like
to try to at least get one female comic
in this show I just think it balances
yeah everything yeah but you're funny if
you were a dude you're a bad
motherfucker you guys are like heavy
weight and light heavyweight champion
tell you what I like about your show is
that it's old-school stand up because
stand ups started in strip club oh yeah
we were the openers for the titty I did
not know that yeah that's where it all
started it makes sense everything makes
sense we're just going back home but
then here's the best part you get you
get your laughs you get that and then
just like you said you love chaos there
is like a chaotic element because you'll
do like either some role play
question-answer or like wet t-shirt but
like some twist on it like you know one
of these created like a lot in it or
some shit like there's always something
yeah there's always the blood wet
t-shirt contest we kill a Red Cow and
blood on strippers it's really popular
there's a chaos I know it is K it's like
I my favorite moments and naughty shows
is when the crowd is absolutely quiet
yeah and then the bit ends and they just
go fucking nuts
because as the comedian sounds can be
very scary but when you're setting up
your punchline and you're like endure
that and there's nobody's talking in the
room and it's like the quiet you're
like that's gold right there if you pull
the pin right right yeah then you drop
the punch I get boom yeah best feeling
ever and that's what I really love it's
a DD Theatre
yeah I've created it so it's like you
know like three to five minute bits and
it's just in the Congress get ten
because it's hard to tell you know good
comic to do five minutes so they do ten
and then it's just turn and burn turn
and burn turn and you got videos do you
guys have these great videos which and
what I'm yeah I've been shooting lot
great videos but now I kind of want to
turn it into like a festival like I've
been blessed of red bands put some
really funny videos in there and I want
people to start sending me their funny
videos like if it's three minutes and
it's like risque shit you know I would
love to show it in my show that's kind
of where I want to get it to it's like
kind of a festival of all that is dirty
and naughty but that's the thing it
really kills me and Tom and I have this
argument all the time of like what is
naughty
what is it what is dirty anymore it's
like give me a fucking break why are we
so offended like you said back when
Kinison and I even Bill Hicks why I'm a
huge fan I'm a huge fan what happened to
that dialogue and why is everything
reverted now back I mean we've gone
backwards in society and I just think
the suits have such control over like
comedy now that they've just watered it
down so much that if you kind of have in
a weird opinion it's like it's hard to
know what to do with you the industry
like sound effects of punchlines now
fucking nuts or draw it on a fucking
post-it not only that or did you ever
what like you know I don't watch we
don't watch a lot of scripted like
sitcoms or anything like that scripted
shows really we don't watch that many
and like every once in a while you know
somebody you'll hear it so much talk
about a show you'll be like alright I'm
gonna sit and watch the show and you
watch a show that's like number one
either overall or number last time slot
and you're like what the fuck is going
on like it's so bad
yeah and either it if it's if it's live
it has the laugh track and you're like
that Jesus Christ man or you're like
this is what they're like this is
perfect this is so weird
it blows your mind especially if your
your your career like the path you chose
is to try to create jokes and that's
right and then you're like this is this
is what's the best this is number one
and that's how you feel we grew up on
look at Sanford and Son yeah
two black guys living in a fucking
junkie yeah yeah cuz all they want to do
is throw the same thing against the wall
it's like you know I was talking
somebody there's like four shows on
storage wars it's like four fucking
shows how many on why is there one how
many cake ones yeah no shit that's the
worst they started doing stand-up
because I didn't want to work a shit job
so I moved to Hollywood to become a
comedian now every shows about people
with shit jobs or something in a garage
I got a tow truck yeah I got a tow truck
you know I told you yeah and we're
supposed to like them yeah it's like the
parking enforcement show I why is that
on Tel Aviv ours
yeah they're the biggest assholes on the
planet as black people need a hit show
yeah they do radio yeah that show is
just nothing that's a hundred percent of
the show black chicks don't give a fuck
black chicks are black chicks yeah I
used to fight with black girls watch
junior high yeah cuz I was a mouthy
little punk or angry girl and I would
fucking talk shit to black girls and
fight with them in black chicks
fuck the rumble oh I mean I say fight
loosely I mean I got the shit beat out
of me yeah the reason publicly that that
show doesn't get like some racial
labeling to it is because they shoot it
in Philly in Detroit so it is black
people yelling at black people yeah it
was in another city and it was like
white person yelling at a black baby
like this show is not cool but it's it's
literally a non-stop have you ever seen
the first 4800 that's Tommy's wheelhouse
yeah dude I love the show it's my
favorite show yeah but there's so many
black criminals on there they had to
create a show they had to create a show
yeah
to counter that right do you ever see
the show where they tell it from both
sides of like criminal and the sheriff
the criminals in that show always white
right there was maybe one black guy
because they had a counter of course
black guys killing each other for 20
bucks well that's the first 48 yeah and
then they started to also you could tell
there was like an emphasis on let's also
feature black and Hispanic detectives
more Oh 100 not just white guys
confident 100% like in Miami with it
like we don't even speak English it's
all like they bring this view and this
is when they have a couple when they
have a white crime you know they bring
extra cameras it's like big deal dude
yeah you gotta get this down because and
it's always math whenever it's black
people to crack whenever it's white
people it's math and I talked about this
on stage what about the first 48
whenever I play a city that had that
they shoot in you know like if I do
Louisville or Miami I always bring up
the first 40 cuz I love the show I love
it and and I talk about how my favorite
element of that show is the
interrogation when they when they get
the guy in there and they go like hey
man and they slide like like a picture
over and they're like you know Terrence
and the guy were like nah man they're
like you don't know me I mean I've seen
him but I don't know yeah like cuz he
lives in your neighborhoods like I've
seen him I seen him on a bike one time
what's up and then they'll be like well
where were you on that like Friday night
in the guy be like I got was just
hanging out smoking smoke with my
partners and then they'll be like we
have footage of you entering the
commedia story he'll be like yeah shot
him they only start off like that
they're talking to their girlfriend who
just busted them cheating on that right
right I always think they could talk
their way out that smooth criminal you
don't say oh come on man I don't know
um I got kids I think they tried to talk
to you like Oh mr. smooth guy the worst
is when they're getting out of a car and
go see oh I wasn't driving and like dude
I just got I just pulled you over and
pulled you out of the cart no that
wasn't me like that seriously is
conversations on oh yeah it is the thing
that impresses me the most I've seen I
don't know how many episodes of the
first 48 say fucking a hundred okay out
of a hundred episodes twice with guys
that are guilty
have I seen them go I want to talk to a
woman if you're listening and you're
gonna kill somebody you have a chance
and your chance is by lowering up and
here's another thing here's another tip
here's another tip if you are on the
first 48 don't sign the paper so they
can show you a specially if you're
ratting yeah and a rat somebody
sometimes you'd be like yeah was saying
do you think the first tell you could
blob the whole you can blur the whole I
know that's parents yeah
that's fucking parent yep do you think
they're just like will give you a
PlayStation 3 if you sign this paper do
you think it's something like that I
think it's actually I think that's a lot
of people's desire to be on television I
put a camera in front of people like
fuck yeah I wanna be you ever try to
shoot outside of LA you can walk in the
people's houses they don't care they're
like thank you Oh camera yeah come on
taxicab confessions people will talk
about you know fucking dogs or whatever
and they sign the release yeah cheating
on their spouses and everything on
camera and I HBO yeah yeah I know I have
a second family that should I know about
a sign of well that I Casey Anthony like
she wants go on Howard Stern I'm like
you're crazy you say yeah that brings
about this is something we always talked
about - doesn't it blow your mind when
you watch one of these like HBO shows
that like someone will be like uh and
you know my family doesn't know that I'm
a fucking prostitute and you're like
well now you're right yeah you just told
a lot I was like where someone will be
like nobody knows yet that I'm on
well know everything and how do you not
know that like interventions coming oh
yeah yeah we're doing to document well
your intervention no no no you should
know when they have you spell your name
like I do on every episode yeah I'm Sam
I am they get so excited when they have
a hot chick on drugs cuz they'll just
run promos for that forever
yeah the meth head and she's smoking hot
everybody tune in to intervention that
was the best one ever she was so hot so
beautiful
and her husband was like like he was he
was like and then she started doing meth
and she's fucking the whole city yeah
and there's guys there's guys coming in
my wife I'm gonna blame fittings like
now there's just guys that just come
inside my wife bleep him out and he was
a fucking like a total hillbilly who you
know was like you can do whatever you
want like I'm gonna talk shit about it
but I'm never scoring anything as hot as
you again yeah yeah totally tolerated it
it just paused this video this was a
video of people fighting and look what I
posited on I'm pregnant nigga I don't
want to fight you what about the
McDonald's one where the fucking
everybody's fighting outside McDonald's
yeah yeah one chicks fucking pregnant
there is that one in bird oh yeah that's
the one the burger commercial fucking
pregnant no but the one where they had
the I guess it was a tranny you didn't
see that one no do you ever see the fat
guy in the nerdfighting at a Burger King
and the nerd just gets up and they just
start wrestling wait it's like hilarious
fucking amazing there's a lot of shit
going on at Burger King McDonald's man
yeah well in little towns that's where
you hang out yeah meet me at the Burger
King me don't bring no trouble yeah
bring some meth because we want to do
one do nothing very fast that's what I
don't understand why you're doing meth
in the mill fucking nowhere take down
these whoppers man but it's made of like
battery acid and histamine and it's not
an act like it's heroin I again it's a
poppy it's in a field cocaine
excellent but man I was like the drag
this reminds me this reminds me this is
a celebration
uh New York has passed game
and this is one of my favorites it's one
of my favorite videos which name of this
video no kaswell's ice cream truck it's
fucking dirty Jenny remix graduation I'm
so happy for them but yeah Mme hasn't
been legalized yeah we should just call
them gay weddings but fucking bothered
me doesn't it kind of bother you that
they beat California yeah fuck is that I
get that but you get on a shout outside
of LA and buck in San Francisco this is
red red is California it blows my mind
weed in New York doesn't have weed yeah
yeah but we only legalize it because
we're broke as fuck if we had money they
wouldn't legalize weed they just got it
just they can't afford to prosecute it
any night I know that this point has
been made before but I literally think
about this all the time it's gonna you
if your position is anti gay marriage
you are literally going it to look
exactly like somebody who's like well
blacks shouldn't eat in our restaurants
though percent like you're saying that
these like who cares I understand if
you're like I don't not down with
different lifestyles of shit but when
you say that like a group of people
don't have certain civil rights so if
you're insane man it's crazy
they really what they it's weird because
when you hate somebody is for two
reasons usually one is they did
something to you and you're mad them for
do two is you're scared you really want
to be that it's like why people hate the
Yankees cuz they want their team to be
the Yankees right and by all the players
right so if you're homophobic like
violently homophobic scuzz you can't
suck all the dick
you won't know absolutely Tom by the way
I love the fact that you always think
about gay marriage though yeah you
really yeah at least once a day yes so
weird and then they're gonna get married
and then they're gonna want to get
divorce and it's gonna be like what's
three people divorce rate sixty percent
now it's like over this is the other
thing that I get excited about besides
Cox
in general no totally is that you think
about just like the benefit of a whole
group of people that all actually have
much more money than like oh yeah
they're psycho couples know what that'll
do to the economy I mean think about
just like the wedding business alone is
going to explode in that like a like a
huge huge low to come it's gonna be how
greater those weddings gonna be because
all the wedding planners are gay yeah
it's gonna be fucking every single ones
like us opening our own comedy club yeah
it's it's gonna be like every weddings
gonna be like a great gatsby party like
I'm gonna top rate yeah so that's guys
fucking you know it's gonna be like over
the top my sweet 16 of weddings I'm just
gonna have like uh sure the food they're
gonna have the best food parties music
you know Elton John's gonna be at all of
them it's gonna be great it's gonna be a
fucking over-the-top multimillion-dollar
generation is that nobody gets to you
know I mean one thing about living in LA
is there's a humongous gay population
and not just a gay population the gay
population I mean we make fucking
honestly we make San Francisco look like
a bunch of fucking butch lumberjack guys
because we're so flaming gay compared to
San Francisco they're just gay yeah
Allen LA we're in the business of gay or
different types of gay like Silver Lake
is like the family marriage gay where we
live and then West Hollywood is like
that's face me right fuck I go to West
Holly
what the good aids is yeah
well they've almost cured that shit man
they're really close yeah Magic Johnson
and Clinics it says seriously it's a
picture of Magic Johnson and it's called
magic clinics magic clinics dot org and
then it says abracadabra your age is
gone that would be hilarious and great
marketing I could just see a bunch of
suits sitting around okay how are we
gonna push this you've got age you want
to get rid of it how are we gonna make
magic Johnson sell this abracadabra
Abra Abra cuz I do love though I mean
obviously it's a great it's a great
cause
to like to start clinics and stuff but I
do love that magic has found a way to
turn getting HIV into profit do the guys
all want a bill almost clear wait yeah I
used to joke about that like if you want
to put someone in charge of Iraq put
fuckin magic Johnson dude yeah that
guy's made so much money in development
he'll have Baghdad looking like Orange
County in a fucking week yeah I do the
guys made Gazoo I mean did Starbucks in
Compton no way did that
that's visionary shit and when he did
that it exploded it took off and he sold
his shares in that so he wants to buy a
football - yep and now he's got he's got
movie theaters
Magic Johnson TGIF not theaters you want
to go to but he does have some movie
yeah oh yeah and they uh and he always
has this like this opening thing he says
kind of like what's-his-face with the
improv like Todd glass yeah magic
Johnson does his thing about please
don't shoot up my theater like hey y'all
we disrespect nobody or nothin up here
we just wanna enjoy the show so hang out
y'all would you know okay hi this is
Barry White please join me on Friday
Saturday and Sunday so we're the first
fuckin bang I'm cuttin to put this back
on me
hi this is Barry White and Paul Quinn
College cordially invite you to a
weekend in Texas on Friday Saturday one
time yet do it over puppet hi this is
Barry White and Paul Quinn College
cordially invites you to a beautiful
weekend in Waco Texas on Friday
this asshole fuck these words I learned
I mean that's the word that he don't
even need you know it's so weird that
Barry White was the lover and he was
like a giant fat fuck I'm gonna cut this
at all
can we turn this into a ring time this
is Barry White and Paul Quinn College in
court coordinated cordially invite your
ass to come on down
I would go to Calipari white and Paul
Quinn College cordially invites you to a
beautiful weekend on Friday Saturday
this is amazing right and Paul Quinn
College and make it your own words dude
at this point
fuck the script amazing come on like you
can't even you know guys that can do the
full range and yeah you can't you can't
imitate that really have you seen a
Marvin Gaye do the national anthem at
their like 1984 all NBA all-star game no
it's the greatest thing you will ever
see in your life really it's so amazing
you're like wow really dude like
goosebumps like I just Coke and it's the
craziest things like yeah it's right
here
somebody told me that about I think it
was was it are Kelly on who was somebody
saying that about are Kelly on jimmy
kimmel or something where they were like
that's the most amazing and then as the
NBA commissioner hated it
I'm like yeah old guy oh no this was way
before Stern Stern was like shitty
people live forever and good people good
yeah that's why I'm not really worried
about retirement I think my days
we got it we got to get out of here I
had such a fun time I loved it it was
good to get to know it was fun listening
to your guys's podcast I get to listen
once in a while you know less chaos but
you know no it's great I like how you do
five minutes up front of you guys talk
and I think I might do that too yeah all
right thanks Sammy I'd do this anytime
Matt so he cancels call me all day bye
mommy bye mommy bye mommy bye mommy